[MUSIC]
All right, JP.
The developer just finished
up the validation rules.
And I know that you've got
your flight to Hawaii, and
I've got some rest and
relaxation to catch up on.
So, I can finally close this
pesky rules file, right?
>> Well, I mentioned authentication,
authorization, and validation.
You've done two of three.
>> JP, you're killing I me.
More rules?
Then, I guess those validation
rules are pretty important, and
the data is looking a lot cleaner.
>> Right, and
remember none of the validation rules
are checked when something is deleted.
Meaning someone could just delete the
whole database with some JavaScript and
also, what's the point of having
someone log in without validation?
>> Okay, okay,
then I guess the developer and
I could read up a little
bit more on authorization.